leute ganz wichtig die ganzen sachen
auch hier aus diesem video sind
angekommen also hier ist alles drin
celina musste nochmal verwalten wenn du
das siehst alina kommt vorbei hier ganz
viel spaß wieder und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video heute ich hoffe
natürlich euch jedes gut ich habe heute
leider noch mal zeit clean
wir haben schon ein paar videos gedreht
und ich habe sie jetzt dazu überredet
weil ich noch was übrig haben hätte so
nennt sich das team vertreten das lernt
man irgendwann lernen und ich habe jetzt
folgende video idee vorgeschlagen es ist
ja gerade im trend dass man irgendwas
nach dem alphabet macht und wir bestellt
einer komplett sachen von avis und die
bestellung und packen die dann in einem
neuen pfad aus musst du dich noch mal
hier hin bewegen und dann packen wir es
an die rechnung kommt der ist es sehr
ruhig cash-bestand von mir an dich damit
zwei leichen noch mal hin genau das geht
dann direkt angriff so in 50 jahren wird
nicht mehr mit geld sondern auch mit
richtigkeit
heute abend habe ich auch nicht mit geld
zu haben und wichtigkeit
also es geht los mit ok hast eine idee
wir könnten theoretisch eingeben
dann kommt er
dass er jetzt so machen sie nicht lustig
über airports was möchte davon er habe
trotz edward cave oder wir nehmen acryl
nails kit das doch gut für dich oder ja
aber dann kannst du dir neuer machen
abgehalten bisschen habe ich jetzt keine
richtige richtung da kannst du hier was
aussuchen ersten angreifen möchte lieber
die haben oder die hier für 10 euro was
kostet so ein solinger in der damals
richtig professionell
das ist geht es lustig ja wie thorsten
das ja hier zehn euro
was andere ist okay dann schnell wie
wäre es mit amazon feier stick oder was
ist anders sohn alex ist ein fake alex
weiß ich gar nicht
alkohol alkohol ja dann das ganze auch
alkohol besteht dabei aber gibt es hier
alkohol
ach ja es gibt wirklich alkohol tage
komplettes alkohol mit meinen us
diskutiert also hier alkohols break das
er am und wichtig es auch zu sagen wir
orientieren uns nur nach dem namen von
dem produkt nicht also gut dass sogar
das zufälligerweise artemisia irgendwas
aber wir steht alkohol spray drauf
deswegen kaufen das ist okay und so
machen wir das jetzt mit einem
buchstaben so was sie mir doch was für
mich
welchen fenstern schön also nein du
musst dir natürlich nicht anziehen
du kannst du ja dann theoretisch ich
denke dass durch schenke den dann und
wenn du dir gefällt kannst du den
die sind doch alle gut aus ich mache
jetzt immer so kurz sagen ja sich drauf
hier
dann können können wir dass ich richtig
jetzt dicke möpse gast auf dem foto
also den video gemacht machen wir weil
das haben alex nach größe xl und welche
farbe
du hast ja welche farbe daten für dich
jetzt nur theoretisch xxl fünf euro euro
schnäppchen 68 nur knapp weiter geht es
mit zehn brauchst du hast ja immer du
hast gesagt eine kamera ist einfach so
aber egal wir kommen müssen da jetzt
eine kamera für 10 euro wir schauen wir
von einer speicherkarte 512 zwei euro
brauchst du so was geht da ja das ist
wahrscheinlich ein komplex jetzt drauf
das ist die pranken dich hier so und
wenn du jetzt aus willst du musst jetzt
hier nämlich die größe wählen und wenn
man jetzt 512 gb
das würde ich gerne mal wissen
das ding mit diesem adapter und memory
card plus card reader
ich will das mal ich würde es nämlich
gern müssen deswegen kaufen und zu
machen also eine kamera speicherkarte
normalerweise um das hat zu vergleichen
kostet eine jetzt in die kamera lassen
wird die 500gb 100 euro mindestens
dann machen wir weiter mit dem
dress for the droid hd kameras und die
pianistin us-drohnen ich habe schon so
viele drohen gestellt dass es irgendwann
langweilig deswegen würde ich also ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich würde hier
die presse wo man eigentlich bevorzugen
sommer
das wäre das beste für mich weil das ist
günstig drei euro so unternehmen wir das
doch marie ist drei euro kostet so viel
wie gut wir gehen ja für dich da raus
weil du ja theoretisch das auspacken wo
sie muss das jetzt nicht anziehen da
keine angst aber du kannst ja dann so
behalten welche farbe möchte zu haben
blau euro sechs euro
da muss ich mir das jetzt noch mal
überlegen tatsächlich als nächstes
elektrik/elektronik belässt kann diese
das im feld von dieser lässt macht oder
wie auch immer was natürlich auch die
billig haben die boxer kann ich mir die
bestellen
auf dem foto sieht immer gut aus aber
ich glaube ich ist es auch dass ich
würde ihnen m tragen
ich bin ich zufrieden mit lassen wir so
durchgehend kaufen das ist halt der
nächsten partner zu tun
das ist von diesem minecraft kripo oder
wie länger steak auf das ist
unrealistisch dass das ist nicht lustig
du bist 120 cm groß mit
dann nehmen wir das so machen wir es bis
zu 150 andere unternehmer die 100
conti meter passt ja schon ungefähr
abc.de fdp hat das ist schön dass ich
den schritt den gürtel habe ich
tatsächlich letztens bestellt also neben
ein paar das gerade in shenzen
achso wir nehmen wir einfach okay denn
im wald davon dann okay aber es ist der
erste haben
hast du die ganze station ist was gibt's
hier handwerks vor wochen ein gutes
format oder immerhin männer also ja ich
will dir noch eine freude machen
tragbare hansi flick bat toilettenpapier
seiten wenn da was ist twitter wissen so
seiten blätter die du in die hand
deutlich schön dann nehme ich die in
lila
das sind jetzt 14 tage egal wie iphone
als roh oder alter hier kommen wir nur
einfach es gibt sogar du kannst
neuerdings auch bairisch iphones kaufen
würde ich jetzt hier nicht empfehlen
aber es gilt anscheinend habe ich schon
kann ich das auch hier
ich bestelle mir dann hier aber lieber
was anderes na ja da habe ich auch schon
wenn es viele ja das ist eine gute idee
ich habe mir nämlich das iphone 11
gegönnt 1 von 11 bis 15 euro für eine 15
euro für eine fade gucci case almeida
hat ist mir das geld nicht wert ja das
finde ich gut
ich hätte gerne kostenlos ja ich hätte
gerne patrick ich will plant
du musst jetzt mal den iren ihr tadeusz
snape landwirt zu mir zutrauen dass sich
damit lange herumreden
brauchst du noch einen deutschen box ich
glaube sogar die habe ich schon
praktisch 86 cent das ist ich habe
glaube ich für 20 euro damals sein
körper habe ich dir auch dank gefragter
richtig auftreten benziner richtigen
übrig und zwar habe ich tatsächlich mal
so waffen bei uns bestellt und dann habe
ich die ausgepackt und die den zuschauer
mit sondern hat sich herausgestellt drei
davon waren höchst illegal in
deutschland und auch sie nicht besitzen
massaker an waffen sondern langes messer
dann so einen schlagring mit seiner
spitze dran und kohlschreiber der so
raus und da ist ein messer drin und das
habe ich dann besser nicht hoch wlan
oder 0 60
richtig mobil fliegt genau und kann
damit leute haben ja aber so
taschenmesser sind soweit ich weiss
erlaubt sonst würden wir das hin zu dir
nach hause
welches kannst dir am besten teil eins
also das kleinste auch in schwarz wir
machen eine mit anwalt so als nächstes
kommen wir haben jetzt mal ausgelassen
weil so wie sie es sonst viel zu lange
guck mal wie teuer 283 euro um an diesen
aktionen aus damit man mir fällt ein ich
hab noch nix also keine original nein
das waren 1 jahr
bei den frauen
nein
und sie hörten wie sich jetzt also ich
komme alles auf klar ist ja immer so
griff er warum valencia gesagt ich mache
jetzt diese stagnation gäste das sogar
festgenommen einer von 4000 euro
die da im konferenzsaal er ja schöne
schuhe deswegen bestellen lieber zahlen
okay kommt möchten dass für eine perücke
kaufst für dich das heißt perücke
englisch auf deutsch bestimmt wäre kein
englisch blood du kannst kardashian
weißt du nicht was wird gereicht du
weißt auch ein blazer gleiche deswegen
denkt gern blaue hand gehabt oder pink
haare oder irgendwie kommt sogar aus die
wird aus deutschland verschickt war es
heißt welt sind so was hier oder die
sonne rainbow da kommt ihm war für dich
das wetter super stehen das heißt c d e
f g h i j k
sicher wissen beide brücken tragen dann
in die videos perücke eine sperre
was meinst du kannst mir hier gut stehen
ich glaube wir haben mittlerweile
einstellungssache oder reicht vom einen
noch arbeiten immer noch z
ganz halt vorbild des vaters mir oder
auch zur bad homburg jetzt kommen wir
die ganzen spanische nacht vor das alte
kummer mit regenbogen da waren wir noch
nicht so wenn so leute jetzt schau mal
wie teuer alle produkte sind wobei ich
auch noch ein paar andere sachen im
warenkorb etwas fester
vor allem der fall sein 114 der versand
kommt auch bei vielen glaube ich noch
oben drauf das ist einfach 240 gesagt
immer noch weniger als ich gedacht
dieses den versand zu buche also ich
habe jetzt gerade 30 produkte im
warenkorb für 232 euro mit versand 181
euro dann hab ich ja dieses cash sondern
auch dieser gutscheincode also an sich
werden das jetzt 3 301 euro wir sehen
uns dann einfach circa 1 ja wenn es gut
läuft drei wochen dann ist das ok und du
musst noch mal in gang kommen ja um das
weil dann auszubringen ok also heute
feiere ich darauf checkt celina update
klima aber hier den kanal und wir sehen
uns dann im laufe der woche wieder
gibt's neues video
haut rein